BETTER, OR REPUBLICANS DO NOT
DESERVE TO BE IN THE MAJORITY.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING US FOR REACTION, IS
SOUTH CAROLINA REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN WALL OF NORMAN WHO
JOINS US FROM CHARLOTTE.
AND HERE IN WASHINGTON, IS
RICHARD GOODSTEIN, SMILING LIKE
THECA CAT WHO ATE THE CANARY,
ATTORNEY, DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU HAVE THE HOUSE,
YOU HAVE THE SENATE, AND YOU GOT
THE WHITE HOUSE, AND NOW WE HAVE
SPEND-O-RAMA WHICH I IMAGINE
BARACK OBAMA MUST BE WATCH
SOMETHING WHERE COMFORTABLY AND
THINK IG GOT TO HAND IT TO YOU,
YOU GUYS CAN DO IT BETTER THAN I
CAN.
YOU CAN SPEND THAT MONEY BETTER
THAN I CAN.
WHAT'S GOING ON, CONGRESSMAN?
>> WELL, LAURA, WHAT DID YOU
SAY, DEAD FISH?
THAT'S WHAT I THINK THIS
SPENDING BILL IS, THE OMNIBUS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY AN INSULT
TO GET A 2,200 PAGE DOCUMENT AND
GET 16 HOURS TO READ IT.
I HAVE TO READ 137 PAGES AN
HOUR, AND DIGEST IT.
AND NOW, WE EE ON A TWO-WEEK
VACATION, REALLY?
THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
WE HAVE GOTTEN THE 1
APPROPRIATIONS OVER, BACK IN
SEPTEMBER, THE 12
APPROPRIATIONS.
WE HAVE TO MAKE A CHANGE.
I'M TIRED OF IT.
AND I, ALLOW WITH A LOT OF OTHER
MEMBERS, I'M A MEMBER OF THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS, VOTED AGAINST
THE RULE TODAY, WE SIMPLY WERE
NOT ELECTED TO BANKRUPT THIS
COUNTRY.
AS CONGRESSMAN BRAT SAID, YOU
KNOW, WE ARE SADDLING OUR
CHILDREN WITH DEBT.
YOU DO THE MATH, EVERY TAXPAYER,
A LITTLE UNDER $200,000.
>> Laura: STUNNING.
>> IT'S SAD.
>> Laura: I HAVE TO PLAY THIS
SOUND BITE FOR YOU.
NANCY PELOSI, WHO ALSO SEEMS
VERY HAPPY, SHE HAD AN EXTRA
SPRING IN HER STEP TODAY, SAID
THIS, LET'S WATCH.
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF REGULAR ORDER
WHY THE REPUBLICANS THOUGHT THAT
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA.
WELL, I THINK ONE OF THE REASONS
THEY RUSHED IT THROUGH, POSTING
IT LAST NIGHT, TAKING IT ON THE
FLOOR TODAY, NOT HONORING THE
THREE-DAY RULE, THEY DIDN'T WANT
THEIR COLLEAGUES TO SEE WHAT WAS
IN THE BILL.
>> Laura: WELL, SHE'S FAMOUSLY
SAID YOU HAVE TO PASS IT TO SEE
WHAT'S IN IT.
2,000 PLUS PAGES.
WE STACKED IT UP LAST NIGHT,
GUYS, NO ONE IS READING THIS
BILL, FACE IT, YOU VOTE ON IT,
GET THE HECK OUT OF TOWN.
THE SENATE LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING
ON VOTE ON IT TONIGHT, THEY SEE
THE WRITING ON THE WALL.
RICHARD GOODSTEIN, LOOK, I'M
EMBARRASSED TONIGHT AS A
REPUBLICAN.
AND THAT MIGHT NOT SELL ON TV
AND MAYBE OTHER NETWORKS GOING
TO DO ALL SEX ALL THE TIME,
HIGHER RATINGS, BUT I FIND THIS
TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT.
WE DOECHBLT THE MONEY FOR THE
SPENDING, REPUBLICANS CAMPAIGNED
ON THIS AND DEMOCRATS, IF I'M
YOU, I'M SITTING BACK AND GOING
WHAT DO WE HAVE TO DO NOW, GOOD
STUFF.
>> I FEEL YOUR PAIN, SERIOUSLY.
I KNOW WHERE YOU'VE BEEN AND
WHERE SEAN AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN
ON DEFICIT SPENDING.
AT LEAST WHEN BARACK OBAMA WAS
RUNNING UP TRILLION DOLLAR
DEFICITS WE HAD THE GREAT RECESS
TO RECOVER FROM.
EVERYBODY IS BOASTING ABOUT HOW
GREAT THIS ECONOMY IS.
AND TO RUN TRILLION DOLLAR
DEFICITS IN THE FACE OF THAT?
REALLY IS NOT RIGHT.
AND YOU TALK WITH SEAN EARLIER
ABOUT STICKING TO PROMISES.
WHETHER IT'S THE BORDER WALL OR
BALANCING THE BUDGET OR BRINGING
JOBS BACK, YEAH, AS YOU PUT IT,
KONLD DONALD TRUMP KNEW HOW TO
WIN IT LEX.
HE SAID THINGS THAT EVERYBODY
WHO KNEW POLICY KNEW HE KOORNLT
DELIVER ON.
>> Laura: I DON'T AGREE WITH
YOU.
YOU CAN BUILD A WALL.
WE CAN PUT A MAN ON THE MOON, WE
CAN DO ALL OF THE INNOVATION
TECHNOLOGY, I THINK AMERICA
COULD SOLVE PRETTY MUCH ANY BIG
PROBLEM AHEAD OF IT.
IF IT WANTS TO.
BUT IN WASHINGTON, RICHARD, IT'S
BOTH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS,
I'M NOT LETTING DEMOCRATS OFF
THE HOOK, THEY'RE BIG SPENDERS,
TOO.
THEY JUST WANT TO KEEP IT GOING.
THE LOBBYISTS GET PAID, THE
LAWYERS GET THE MONEY.
I'M FORMER LAWYER, BELIEVE ME,
IT'S NICE TO CHARGE $700 AN
HOUR.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DEMAND REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHAT BANG ARE WE GETTING FOR THE
BUCK, IS IT GOING TO MAKE THE
MILLENIALS SAFER AND PROSPEROUS
AND HAPPIER?
CONGRESSMAN CHIME, IN BUT THE
DEMOCRATS DIDN'T GET EVERYTHING
THEY WANT, REPUBLICANS, NO ONE
GETS EVERYTHING THEY WANT, I'M
NOT GOING TO COME HERE TONIGHT
SAYING THE PRESIDENT WAS GOING
TO GET EVERYTHING.
IT SEEMS TO ME HE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY, OR HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY, TO GO TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SAY I
CAMPAIGNED ON THIS, I THINK THIS
IS CRITICAL FOR THE FUTURE OF
THE COUNTRY, IF THE GOVERNMENT
HAS TO SHUT DOWN BECAUSE BOTH
PARTIES DON'T WANT TO PROTECT
OUR COUNTRY THAT'S SAD.
MAYBE WE NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT.
I THINK HE HAD TO DO THAT.
>> WELL, YOU GOT TO, YOU CAN'T
LET THIS PROCESS CONTINUE WITH
THE THREAT OF A SHUTDOWN.
I WAS PERFECTLY WILLING TO HAVE
A SHUTDOWN.
AND SIT UP IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
FOR SIX MONTHS OR AS LONG AS IT
TAKES TO NOT HAVE THE GIVEAWAY
PROGRAMS WE HAVE HAD.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE A HUGE PART OF
THIS.
LOOK, IF YOU LOOK AT THE VOTE
TODAY, ON THE RULE, WHICH ALL
THE RULE WAS IS ALLOWING THE
BUDGET TO BE VOTED ON, IT BARELY
PASSED 211-207, AND 182
DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: YOU NEEDEDTED
DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH REPUBLICANS, THEY NEEDED
THE DEMOCRAT VOTES.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY SUPPORT THIS?
THEY'RE GOING TO SUPPORT IT.
WE HAVE TO GET TO BOLTON.
THIS IS HUGE NEWS, I'M SORRY.
JOHN BOLTON IS REPLACING H.R.
McMASTER TODAY, AND MY GOODNESS,
MSNBC AND OTHERS ARE IN A TOTAL
MELTDOWN, WORLD WAR 3 IS ABOUT
TO HAPPEN.
>> JOHN BOLTON IS KNOWN AS A
HARD LINER.
CLEARLY DIFFERENT THAN OTHERS IN
THE ADMINISTRATION NOW, ON THE
IRAN AGREEMENT FOR EXAMPLE.
AND IT POINTS TO DANGEROUS
SIGNALS.
>> MILLIONS OF VOTERS VOTED
AGAINST IN 2016, VOTED AGAINST
STUPID WARS AND BRINGING THE
BIGGEST HAWK THERE'S EVER BEEN
AND PUT HIM AS HEAD OF NATIONAL
SECURITY IS AWFUL.
>> JOHN BOLTON, HE IS THE HAMMER
AND EVERYTHING IS A NAIL.
>> Laura: I LOVE THAT PHRASE.
COME ON, RICHARD, THE IDEA THAT
BOLTON IS GOING TO ORDER TRUMP
AROUND, YOU'RE GOING TO WAR IN
COUNTRY X, I DON'T THINK SO.
TRUMP IS NOT A MILITARY
INTERVENTIONIST, EVEN DP BOLTON
IS NOR OF A NEO--
>> BUT HE'S IMPRESSIONABLE, THE.
IS.
THE EXPLANATION, McMASTER WAS
MORE FOND OF THE IRAN DEAL AND
THEREFORE TRUMP HAD TO GET RID
OF HIM.
BUT THE POINT IS, WE KNEW WHERE
HE WAS, THE IRAN DEAL, I HIRED
THIS GUY THIS DIDN'T AGREE WITH
ME.
WHY DIDN'T YOU ASK WHEN YOU
HIRED HIM?
JOHN BOLTON IS MORE
INTERVENTIONIST.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS THUMPING HIS DHESHT
ABOUT MEETING WITH KIM JONG-UN,
DOING AWAY WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
NUCLEAR THREAT F WE RIP UP THE
IRAN DEAL WITHIN MONTHS, WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY, IRAN IS
GOING TO BE A NUCLEAR THREAT.
THAT'S A TINDER BOX.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, I THINK
BOLTON, HE HAS EXPERIENCE AT THE
U.N., HE KNOWS THE SWAMP,
DOESN'T AGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT LIKES TO HAVE
DIFFERING VIEWS ON HIS STAFF,
STILL, I THINK.
YOUR REACTION TO ANOTHER
SHAKEUP?
>> IT IS A GREAT HIRE.
WE HAVE HAD BOLTON IN MEETINGS
ON CAPITOL HILL, KNOWLEDGEABLE,
STRAIGHT FORWARD.
HE WILL NOT AGREE WITH THIS
PRESIDENT IF HE REALLY DOESN'T
THINK IT IS IN THE WEST
INTERESTS OF THE COUNTRY.
ONE THING ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP,
HE ENCOURAGES THAT.
HE'S GOING TO BE THE ONE TO MAKE
THE FINAL DECISION.
BUT JOHN BOMB TON, I HAVE THE
HIGHEST RESPECT FOR.
JOHN BOLTON.
WE HAVE NOT INTERVIEWED ANYBODY
IN THE MEETINGS THAT I HAVE HAD
WHERE HE HASN'T ANSWERED EVERY
QUESTION.
HE SAT FOR AN HOUR AND A HALF TO
TWO TALKING ABOUT FOREIGN
POLICY.
THAT'S HIS BAILEY WICK.
WHAT HE LIKES.
I APPLAUD THE PRESIDENT.
IN THE PRESS, MSNBC WHEN HAVE
YOU HEARD THEM COMPLIMENT THIS
PRESIDENT?